really glad that the wild is not like
that because i would
be dead a thousand times over my name is
laura zara i'm a survival specialist
and i've been practicing and teaching
wilderness survival for over 17 years
i participated in five seasons of the
discovery show naked and afraid today
i'll be looking at wilderness survival
scenes and movies and judging how real
they are
unexpected falls and falls in general
are actually one of the biggest ways
people die when they're in the
backcountry it doesn't always have to be
a cliff face it can just be a steep
slope it's definitely something to look
out for
as far as climbing into a horse as a
means of survival
it would totally work the length of time
it would work for is going to be limited
and i think the biggest mistake that he
did was not taking that gut
pile and cuddling it because there's so
much bacteria
and guts that continue to stay alive and
produce heat once the animal's already
dead
so the guts are really where the heat is
there's certain kinds of clothing like
wool that will still keep you warm and
add
some heat even if they're wet i think
being naked you're
already dealing with losing heat through
being wet
and any gusts that are getting in
through that hole so
it seems a little risky to take your
clothes off if you don't have to
[Music]
as he's pulling that gut pile out he
realizes it's warm
and why would you not have it at least
kind of sealing up the door that you're
in i would give this clip a seven
i think that it's pretty smart it takes
a lot of
guts no pun intended pun intended to be
able to do something like this
i've brought with me only the bare
essentials a
knife a roll of duct tape in case i need
to fashion a shelter
i actually think someone on naked and
afraid once brought a roll of duct tape
as their survival item and they're
supposed to be professionals so
take a look at this i tented my pants
i've made myself a nice pants tent
shelter i love that clip i think it's
clearly ridiculous
and yet at the same time he probably did
better than a lot of people
in his situation would do he was looking
at what he had and trying to figure out
how he could creatively use it
now i think taking your clothes off like
your clothes are already a shelter
they're already like your first form of
shelter
so taking them off to make a secondary
shelter
probably isn't going to be great but
it's better than
running around in circles until you're
completely dehydrated and exhausted
those nature's
best mushrooms these little buggers are
damn tasty as well
eating the mushrooms is terrible idea
even when mushrooms are edible
a lot of them in the wild you have to
cook so
yeah he would have died pretty quick um
in that situation if it wasn't for the
mushrooms i would have given michael's
survival skills a four
because he's at least thinking about
what he needs to do
and trying to be creative about it and
that's a great start
[Music]
well he's in trouble but how many times
do wolves actually attack humans and the
answer is
almost never i think there's like a
couple documented cases of that
happening in north america and
i see wolves pretty much every single
time i'm out in the woods wolves are
terrified of people
wolves wanted to hunt people people
wouldn't go in the woods because they're
amazingly effective predators they
outmatch us on every physical front
they just don't have any interest we
don't look like food if you did
run into a extremely desperate wolf who
was thinking about the possibility that
you might be a food source then you want
to make yourself
look as big as possible put your arms up
start yelling
make some noise kick some rocks at it
wolves can run over 30 miles an hour
so running is gonna do nothing
[Music]
i don't know who else has ever used
electric tape but it's not
this rigid stuff that stuff's just gonna
end up breaking off further
probably before it penetrates the wolf's
really thick fur and hide
and i could see him getting more hurt
from doing that
than any benefit it would serve creative
again really like his mindset he's kind
of just willing to do whatever and be
creative to survive
i would give this clip a one because
you're already starting on really false
pretenses i don't like when this myth of
wolves being man eaters man hunters is
perpetuated
[Music]
i'm really super focused at this moment
on what he used for mechanism to get
that much force
on that trap because that was
impressively fast
and strong there's a lot that goes into
making a trap like that
sharpening a bunch of stakes and setting
them
into another log i mean we're talking
hours and then
just setting the trap and coming up with
the right tension
on like the mechanism that's you're
using to trigger it and then finding a
place to put it a trap only works if you
have someone
walk into it so the way you get around
that is either to set
a lot of traps which would take a lot of
time or by
funneling the movement in so it's not
something you can just do on the fly and
expect to work
[Music]
don't push it camouflage is absolutely
useful in survival whether it's you know
in a situation where you're clearly
trying to run from someone or
maybe you're just hunting he had him i
think there were hemlock branches on his
back
but unless he's hiding with his back
towards everyone
it's not going to be useful because the
idea is to break up the form so you
don't look like a person and
i could say the same about his face camo
like maybe do a better job of like
working with your face to make it look
less like your eyes are standing out and
your eyebrows i mean his eyebrows were
so dominant still
so creating some kind of
color scheme on his face where his eyes
and his eyebrows were less
dominant would have done better than
just like smearing stuff everywhere
i would give this a 5. realistically i
struggle
with the time invested in the trap
some really accurate portrayals of
survival skills in here the hand drill
is amazing like spot on
totally would work i think the biggest
problem i have is
when you're trying to forge it's really
hard to get a temperature
that's high enough to forge metal when
you're using wood
i think wood a wood fire can burn at
about 900 or so degrees
you need about 1 500 to start moving
metal otherwise
to get the metal that hot seems really
unlikely to me if i'm
in a survival situation and i don't have
a knife i
will use stone all the time it's
obviously ideal if you have a steel
knife but
by adapting the way that you do things a
stone knife or stone tools can actually
accomplish the same tasks
dealing with metal requires so many
specific things that
stone's going to work for whoever you
need to kill or whatever task you need
to accomplish
i basically just want a knife that has
an edge that
is going to be able to carve wood so for
traps for skinning animals having a
smaller knife anything where you're
carving or doing fine intricate work
something smaller is going to be better
i would give this
clip probably an eight out of ten i
think
it was really surprisingly accurate
the one thing was the fire
another example of animals just
being out to get you in the most
dramatic fashion really glad that the
wild is not like that because i would
be dead a thousand times over grizzly
attacks are
definitely more common than wolf attacks
and it can happen
usually a grizzly is attacking in a
defensive situation
either you surprised it there's a mother
and cub
situation basically you got too close
and it wants to get you away it's not
going to
hunt you and consume you per se it's
just trying to get you on the ground so
you're not moving and then it's going to
take off and run away normally i think
it would be more a case of that
happening when it was a single person
walking along versus like a whole group
around fire
but it can happen
depending on where the bear is a lot of
times they're pretty used to fire
if they're coming into camp and they're
used to stealing food i have a hard time
thinking that if you have a log that's
burning with embers at the end and
you're shoving it into a bear's eye
that it's not going to at least slow him
down a little bit
i wouldn't just wave it in his face i
think that's where where they messed up
a little bit
and everyone else like throw some stuff
at him they didn't even make contact
if they're gonna stay and fight then
fight if it was a situation where you
surprise the bear and the bear starts
attacking and it's just
trying to get away from you then that's
when you want to play dead
stop moving don't move until the bear is
long gone
try to be in areas where you can see
further than you know
20 feet and carry bear spray i would
give this scene one
not saying it doesn't happen but this
was very unrealistic and the way they
responded was just like
come on there's better things you guys
could have done
first of all is that kate winslet which
is just
funny that she didn't like find a door
this time to float on there's a lot of
things i'm not buying in this clip
she basically falls through a perfect
hole of ice i
really struggle with the fact that the
second she hits the water she's just
peacefully passed out
there's no struggle there's no
hyperventilating
like does she just like one of those
fainting goats who comes into a bad
situation and is no longer conscious
that's what it felt like watching this
she was immediately just out and
it can happen you can pass out you can
hyperventilate breathe water
whatever but it happened so soon
how did he find her in there it's
obviously deep water
and she apparently just is comprised of
mostly
fat underneath her clothes because she
was so buoyant
it seemed very improbable for someone to
just float back to the surface
and not float away to the sides of the
hole and be able to be grabbed
he had to run so far to get to that hole
and her body is just right there
is a little too convenient for me to be
okay with
when he was pulling her body out of the
ice it was good that at least his body
was
kind of spread out his body weight
wasn't just centered on the edge
i would rate this clip probably a one
i just don't understand any of it
if i'm trying to learn an area i will
absolutely bring
some kind of book to help me identify
what i'm looking at whether it be
plants animal tracts things like that
it's super useful
to learn it's also very limited you
might get
one picture at one time of the year of a
plant
so to just have one resource and then
use it
to consume something that could
potentially kill you
in my opinion isn't a great idea
[Music]
out in the wild you just have to be
really careful you
are not going to be consuming something
that you're not 100
certain of its identity it's a really
bad idea
and furthermore you're probably not
getting that many calories
it's not going to be the matter between
life or death you can't really
exist off of the few meager calories
you're going to get from a lot of plant
foods
so to run the risk of eating it not
knowing 100
it's like a risk versus reward thing and
it loses out every time
you really can get into trouble very
quickly and there's certain things you
can do
that will really increase that there's
very few things you can actually control
but what you put in your body is one of
those
so don't mess around with anything that
you can't identify 100
i would give this clip a 10 honestly
it's definitely
something that can and did happen
[Music]
this is a remarkably unsmoky fire
wildfires can travel really fast they
can basically travel as fast as the wind
that being said
it really seemed to be traveling on the
ground a lot and it didn't look like
there was any brush there to catch on
fire but it can happen
and fires are super scary and being
caught in one would be
like absolutely terrible if you can
getting upwind of that fire
trying to you know figure out the
direction it's moving in and kind of
move perpendicular to it and get out of
the path of it
because the smoke can take you out
anyone who's ever stood in campfire
smoke
you know what that's like a forest fire
would clearly be
way worse you know carbon monoxide
carbon dioxide all these nasty things
you basically just want to get out of
its path if you can
sometimes um that's kind of impossible
and there's unfortunately a lot of
stories where
people have been caught in situations
like this and didn't make it out even
highly trained people i've actually
read about people who've survived
wildfires by being in
pools or bodies of water and kind of the
key thing
is that you want it to be deep enough
that it's going to cover your whole body
and not just immediately get too hot the
flames can actually pass over the top of
the water so if your body's sticking out
it can definitely
be a bad situation the problem with deep
water would be you know getting
exhausted or just passing out and
drowning but in certain circumstances it
could definitely work
i think it really looked like their only
option and people have definitely done
it and survived
i think the one thing i would have done
differently
would be wetting an item of clothing and
then when i did have to come up and
surface you have a wet
piece of clothing over your face so it's
cooling down that air because that air
is going to be super heated
like that goes into your lungs and even
if there's not smoke just the super
hot air can burn the inside of your
lungs that cool cloth over your face is
gonna not only protect your face from
any
falling embers but it's gonna cool down
the air
and just keep your your skin cool as
well i would probably
give this scene a seven
there's a lot of things with the fire i
have trouble with but they did try they
put thought into it
this could work it's better than nothing
but there were ways that could have been
improved
ice is funny so you can't always tell
the thickness of ice you want it to be
at least four inches to support your
body weight
and there's a few factors that make it
more dangerous whether it's
still or moving water where it is if it
has snow on top
which can actually insulate it like a
blanket and
prevent it from becoming really thick if
you look at ice
generally if it's clear then it's going
to be thick but if it's kind of that
milky color
it means it's gone through processes of
thawing and freezing and
probably isn't that thick or safe and if
you do have to go out on it
you don't want to be running what you
have is your entire body weight coming
down hard and fast
on one point that's small so if you had
to cross something
getting flat spreading your body weight
out there's a million ways they could
have done it
there's definitely a risk of wet
clothing if they were to swim across and
everything got wet and they couldn't
start a fire
they could be in a bad situation being
way back then i think a lot of it would
have been wool clothing
which actually will keep you warm when
it's wet it's not ideal to have it be
wet you're not going to have as much of
the insulating properties but
you'd still be okay if you were moving
and they could just keep moving until
their body heat dried their clothes out
people die in a few minutes in cold
water it's not from hypothermia it's
from
going into that shock and drowning or
losing mobility in their limbs and
drowning
i would give the accuracy of this a one
i think the biggest movie myth in
wilderness survival
is that it's always something big and
dramatic that's coming and trying to get
you and in real survival it's not like
that it's the little things it's the
hypothermia it's dehydration
but it's not as exciting as a grizzly
bear if you enjoyed this video
click above to watch another